alors question y at il vraiment une
montée de l'islam politique en france
est l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
notre décryptage pour en parler nous
sommes avec frédéric et un sinclair
éditorialiste ancien conseiller
politique de dominique de villepin
bonsoir frédéric saint clair à vos côtés
philippe pascot écrivain ancien
conseiller municipal à evry notamment
bonsoir à vous également philippe pascot
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france avant c'est un sujet de
société qui divisent les français à ce
que j'ai délicat l'islam
encore plus si on prononce les deux mots
accolés l'islam politique mais de quoi
parlons nous exactement avant d'en
débattre et de petits frédéric saint
clair alors écoutez le le terme islam
politique a été employée par le par le
ministre n'est pas le sujet du n'est pas
sujet du rapport c'est le sujet du
rapport c'est l'islam radical et le
problème c'est qu'il ya une confusion et
les politiques sont responsables de
cette confusion parce que ils ne
comprennent pas le sujet et malgré les
efforts répétés depuis depuis des années
de la part de toute une partie de la
classe intellectuelle pour essayer de
clarifier les choses
eh bien il ya un brouillard qui
s'installe et qui fait qu'on on mélange
à peu près tout ce rapport là est un
rapport extrêmement sérieux je suis
malheureusement comme la totalité des
français incapables d'y avoir accès
puisque les rapports se multiplient mais
la population n'y a pas accès vous
rappelez probablement qui a eu un
rapport de la dgs si à la fin de l'année
2019 la presse en avait parlé
ce qui mentionnait 150 quartiers tenus
par des islamistes et ce rapport était
apparemment top secret classés
confidentiels aujourd'hui on a un
rapport sénatorial qui devrait
normalement être remis ou qui a déjà été
remis qui devrait normalement être
communiqué à la population et on n'y a
pas accès non plus donc on est en train
de parler de quelque chose que les
français vivent au quotidien dans
certains quartiers mais pas seulement
dans tout un tas de villes de province
mais qui n'a ri qui naquit n'arrive pas
à passer le filtre politique pour
revenir à eux et pour savoir ce que
enfin les politiques ont compris ce
qu'ils sont en mesure
de proposer comme réponse donc on est
dans une situation de blocage à la fois
vis-à-vis d'une seat d'une situation
sociologique qui est qui en piste et et
puis vis-à-vis d'une société une
situation politique où le pouvoir
politique semble paralysée par un
phénomène qui les dépasse 1 philippe
pascot d'accord avec l'analyse de
frédéric saint clair bah il suit pour
moi d'accord sur une future une chose
c'est que la plupart des politiques
aujourd'hui sont complètement dépassés
par ce qu'ils disent et parce qu'ils
font quand on parle d'islam politique ça
veut dire quoi ça veut rien dire
les gens qui parlent de ça ont
simplement peur compliquer leur pias
leur place les gens qui se présentent en
politique et qui sont d'origine entre
guillemets de religion musulmane
c'est des gens modérés moi j'en connais
plein c'est l'essai c'est saïd à grigny
c'est samir à evry mais c'est des gens
totalement modéré qui qui en plus sont
nés en france et qui sont français
donc c'est quoi cet islam politique
c'est simplement des vieux politicards
compper compliquer leur place et que
trouve cette combine pour les encore
stigmatiser une partie de la population
et faire peur aux gens mais il n'ya pas
d'islam politique il ya des connards
dans l'islam comme partout il ya des
connards en politique mais il ya surtout
des politicards qui veulent pas
compliquer leur place eux quand on parle
par exemple la partie comme l'union des
démocrates musulmans même s'il s'en
défend ce parti a fait son fond de
commerce électoral de proposition liée
clairement à al islam est ce qu'on peut
affirmer clairement n'ya pas d'islam
politique quand on fait par exemple
préférence à ce parti qui fait des
scores dans certaines villes comme
maubeuge de très bons scores
frédéric saint clair oui donc sur l'acte
sur la question de l'islam politique
encore une fois mon propos tenait à
différencier islam radical islam
politique on parle pas de la même chose
il ya un islam culturel civilisationnel
qui lui est très présent en france
très présent en france et où les
politiques sont paralysés c'était le
sens de mon propos
il ya effectivement un mii slam
politique aussi mais il est embryonnaire
l'udf donc donc que vous avez mentionné
commencent à émerger
il a changé son programme donc au virage
de l'année 2017 2018
le site internet a été modifié là le
côté républicain a été réaffirmée le
côté communautariste a été mis en
retrait donc le système politique sert
la prise de pouvoir par des personnes
qui se revendiquent de confession
musulmane et qui ne s'adresse pas à
toute la population en tant que nation
mekhissi adresse sous un angle musulmans
existent
il est extrêmement minoritaire donc si
on multiplie les rapports simplement
pour cette frange de musulmans ça a été
très bien dit qui pour une grande partie
d'entre eux veulent s'engager sont
musulmans et sont fiers de leur religion
autant que de leur pays et qu'ils ne
continuent constitue absolument par une
menace pour le pays
à ce moment là on va perdre notre temps
en revanche le rapport de hakim el
karoui commandée par l'institut
montaigne en 2016 était extrêmement
clairs sur ce que j'appelle l'islam
civilisationnel il categorie les
musulmans en six catégories la première
catégorie 18 % ce qui fait à peu près vu
les chiffres qu'on a aujourd'hui du pew
research un million de musulmans qui ne
revendique aucune aucune volonté
d'exprimer leur foi dans l'espace public
ni halal dans les cantines ni séparation
en femmes dans les piscines ni voile
dans la rue donc ils sont intégrés
complètement à la fois au système
politique français nos systèmes
culturels 18% les 90% restants exprime
une rupture culturelle avec la france et
dit les 28% les derniers catégorie 5 et
6 sont en sécession politique on a
beaucoup parlé de ce rapport lorsqu on
focalise notre attention sur la partie
civilisationnel culturel on se rend
compte que la volonté d'exprimer une
culture islamique est très répandue chez
les musulmans il n'y a pas de risque il
n'y a pas de guerre il n'y a pas de
menace pour notre santé pour notre
sécurité physique donc il faut arrêter
de stigmatiser les musulmans il faut
prendre du recul et regarder réellement
ce qu'on veut faire
la question est simple soit on veut en
france protéger la culture française les
traditions françaises et les moeurs
françaises mais à ce moment là il va
falloir que le contrat soit clairement
définie par le pouvoir politique sont
nous
pas et on veut mettre en place une
société multiculturelle mais là aussi il
faut s'adresser aux français leur dire
voilà le projet politique et là y'a une
société culturelle qui va se mettre en
place et vous allez devoir partager
l'espace public avec des cultures qui
sont différentes de la vôtre
le problème ce n'est pas les musulmans
le problème c'est le pouvoir politique
qui n'a pas le courage de poser cette
question aux français et donc les
français ce christ parce qu'ils voient
leur environnement se transformer petit
à petit le jdd
oui le jdd il ya quelques semaines
enfin quelques mois a envoyé un
journaliste à roubaix roubaix cette
ville qui est très très prise par la
communauté musulmane
il écrit dans ces lignes on peut pas
qualifier le jdd de journal d'extrême
droite
il écrit dans ces lignes que le
supermarché le triangle affiches en
français et en arabe et les les
inscriptions dans le supermarché que la
ville de 96 96 mille habitants compte
cette mosquée dont une salafistes et
qu'à l'extérieur du supermarché il ya un
tronc pour la construction d'une
huitième mosquée que les magasins autour
s'appelle l'aziza les mille merveilles
les délices du maghreb que hourriya en
sortant une commerçante voilées de la
tête aux pieds et que s'expriment en dix
ans ici c'est comme au collège fédérer
qui s'incarne à on va redonner la parole
à philippe pascot dans quelques instants
mais je vous propose vous parlez la
réponse des politiques est importante
selon vous justement le ministre le tout
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur a été
interrogé sur ce rapport du sénat qui
pointent donc cette propagation de
l'islam politique écoutez sa réponse
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale eh
oui l'islam politique est un ennemi
mortel pour la république
oui il faut combattre toute forme de
communautarisme il me semble madame que
le miz intérieure est également le
ministre des cultes et qu'en france a et
cités ne veut pas dire la négation de
cette liberté des cultes
madame mon grand-père prier allah
et porter l'uniforme de la république il
m'a semblé que bien des tirailleurs
algériens et bien les supplétifs ont par
ailleurs tout en priant pour leur
religion défendu les valeurs de la
république
philippe pascot sur cette réaction du
ministre de l'intérieur à ce rapport moi
je suis effaré de plus en plus ses bras
jo font référence à leur famille comme
garantie de leur intégrité soit y en a
un qui est née chez les pauvres soit
c'est l'autre qui était chez les
jésuites
ça va ça va d'un dad il a rien nous
apprendre ce brave monsieur il en train
de répandre la peur au lieu de s'occuper
des populations il en train de répandre
la peur et de créer du communautarisme
forcé au niveau des populations
moi j'écoute et frédéric et je suis très
content et je suis d'accord avec son
discours ce que je regrette une fois de
plus c'est comme il était conseiller de
villepin comment ça se fait que villepin
il l'a pas fait quand il était au
pouvoir parce que tous ces gens là qui
nous donnent des bons conseils ne nous
les donne que quand ils sont dans
l'opposition
jamais mon salaire dans la majorité ça
c'est un peu embêtant
oui frédéric laças clair votre arrêt
quand je le peux je ne peux qu'approuver
en ce qui concerne le discours de
monsieur darmana nouveau ministre vous
voyez qu'il ait battu complètement le
sujet central que j'ai évoqués il nous
parle de l'islam en tant que religion
dit mon grand-père prier allah
ce n'est pas du tout sujet ouais la
liberté de religion est assurée par les
libertés fondamentales dans notre pays
on a le droit de croire en qui on veut
ou de ne pas croire et ça sera maintenu
l'islam politique c'est un problème dont
nous avons dit déjà en début d'interview
que c'est un problème mineur
la question c'est l'islam
civilisationnel qu'est ce qu'on fait de
notre culture de nos traditions de nos
moeurs darmanin le pardon gérald
darmanin n'aborde pas cette question là
il est fautif et je pense au regard de
ce que j'ai entendu lui à l'époque où il
était dans l'opposition sous françois
hollande
je pense que son penchant
multiculturelle va le conduire à mener
l'exacte copie de la politique
multiculturaliste d' emmanuel macron
c'est à dire laisser prospérer cette
angoisse civilisationnel parce que les
français ne sont jamais amené à se
prononcer doit-on protéger oui ou non
notre culture si les français disent oui
il faut le faire et à ce moment là il
faut clarifier les choses et tout
interdire si les français disent non à
ce moment là il faut arrêter dans merde
pas redondant bekele le jul et puis
toutes les coupes dans ce rapport la
commission denquête veut créer une base
de données messieurs des élèves
scolarisés à domicile l'obligation pour
les associations de faire la
transparence sur leurs ressources en
particulier celles provenance de
l'étranger et la réactivation de la
police des cultes c'est justement
philippe à secours des points importants
c'est ces ressources qui viennent de
l'étranger tout de même
mais oui c'est un point important mais
excusez moi chère madame ce qu'ils sont
en train de raconter c'est encore du
pipeau il ya longtemps qu'on aurait pu
le faire et ils n'ont toujours pas fait
donc pourquoi il le ferait demain
donc ça c'est encore des effets
d'annoncé de dire qu'on va savoir d'où
vient l'argent
ah oui ça c'est pas la première fois que
je l'entends et c'est pas la première
fois qu'il ne le ferons pas parce que
l'argent qu'elle n'est ce pas de signes
à quoi maintenant ces volatiles ça vient
de n'importe où et quand on donne d'un
côté on reprend de l'autre c'est des
menteurs ces gens là maintenant le
mensonge est devenu professionnel en
politique
ces gens-là nous baratine s'il n'avait
pas laissé des déserts dans les
banlieues je dis bien des déserts dans
les banlieues les extrémistes qu'ils
soient musulmans qu'ils soient de droite
qu'ils soient catholiques intégristes ne
serez pas rentrer dans les quartiers
pour ce faire des familles
les vrais responsables c'est nous est ce
que c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui je
rencontre des gens qui sont depuis 30
ans en france madame 30 ans en france et
qu'il ne parle toujours pas français
est ce que c'est normal que dans les
arrière boutiques des restaurants ont
continué à embaucher des philippins qui
ne parlent que le philippin et qui n'ont
pas de papiers
est ce que c'est normal que dans le btp
on exploite des immigrés en laisse ou
payants et en s'occupant pas de où ils
dorment et comment y vivent et comment
ils apprennent le français
véritables coupables madame du fait
qu'il y ait une extension des familles
extrémistes c'est le désert on a laissé
chez ces gens là on les a laissé croupir
on les a exploitées et maintenant les
montre du doigt
c'est complètement inadmissible frédéric
ça car le mot de la fin
le mot de la fin c'est que je pense
qu'effectivement la la le contrôle des
financements qui viennent de l'étranger
est extrêmement important simplement
pour tout un tas de petites associations
pour tout un tas de deux personnes
privées les financements vont passer par
des canaux qui sont autres que les
canaux officiels
et à ce moment là le contrôle devient
beaucoup plus compliqué il ne réglera
pas comme l'a dit philippe parce qu il
ne réglera pas un attachement
aujourd'hui massif d'une partie de la
communauté immigrée d'une partie de la
communauté française de culture
étrangère à cette culture étrangère et
donc il va y avoir à un moment une
tension supplémentaire dans les
banlieues où les gens vont avoir
l'impression qu'à une stigmatisation
supplémentaire qui est exercée sur eux
parce que la république ne leur offre
d'un côté rien mais accroît la pression
sur la question financière est donc
cette tension va se se s'aggraver
jusqu'à ce que soit on se retrouve comme
le disait gérard collomb face à face
soit comme c'est la plupart des cas
chaque fois qu'il ya une tension de ce
genre là le gouvernement cède
merci beaucoup à tous les arrêts
arrêtons de montrer que les musulmans
je suis désolé il ya des extrémistes
aussi chez les catholiques ceux qui
s'enferment pour nous chanter qu'en
latin qui sont pour le mac qui sont
contre le mariage pour tous ces gens là
c'est aussi des extrémistes et ils sont
aussi minoritaire que le sont les
musulmans salafistes non merci et humour
salafistes un mot les musulmans
salafistes c'est c'est 30% de la
communauté musulmane va en tout cas ceux
qui sont ces sessions politique d'après
le rapport d' el karoui
c'est chez ces gens là que se nourrit
aussi le terrorisme chez les plus
radicalisés on n'a pas de terrorisme
catholique en france
jusqu'à preuve du contraire merci à tous
les deux frédéric sinclair et philippe
pasqua d'avoir été
avec nous